i am inevitable
and i
am
iron man
hey
i
do i know am you're
pretty close actually because you're
because you're
hey dad i'm working wow
yeah yeah it worked for me i got to live
grow up for you i can't answer
i'm sorry it's uh
think i might have made a bad decision
i'm scared to make a mistake
i know and i know it's gonna be tough
for you to let go
but if someone had to do that so
the rest of us could
i'm proud of you
and sad
i'm strong like mom
and i'm happy i'm happy we had the time
that we did
okay and that you were there for me
until you couldn't be
if you're happy i'm
i happy you
[Applause]
i love you three thousand
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the avengers
end game deleted scene of iron man going
into the soul world in the alternate
ending to the movie
we're doing that giant infinity saga box
set giveaway for all the films all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
for how iron man can come back in marvel
phase 4 and marvel phase 5.
so iron man goes into the soul world
when he snaps the nano infinity gauntlet
like everyone is supposed to go into
this way station area as they call it
during the filmmaking process they call
it the way station but technically it's
the soul world
instantly you sense the mechanics of how
this place works for each different
person who uses the infinity gauntlet is
a makeshift version of the campsite from
outside his lake house earlier in the
movie
where iron man found morgenstark playing
in her tent with pepper potts rescue
armor from the comics
the place itself is meant to be some
meaningful shared plays from each
person's history
that's why for thanos it was this place
with young gamora on her homeworld
it's the place where he decided to adopt
her so that's why it's so meaningful for
him
adult morgan stark played by catherine
langford who you all probably recognize
tells him that everything worked out she
got to grow up and have a happy life
with pepper potts everything is okay
and he doesn't need to worry about
whether or not he made the right
decision in sacrificing himself to snap
the infinity gauntlet
or do the whole big time heist and bring
everyone back the really interesting
part too is that she also tells them
that she can't say
whether or not he's alive in the future
i can't say about you
mostly because marvel doesn't have a
contract with robert downey jr to come
back in the live-action movies
beyond the black widow movie there's a
rumor that he's coming back in a scene
for black widow but it might just wind
up being a deleted scene from captain
america civil war
that's kind of a separate thing i'll
talk about it during my black widow
videos when they start dropping trailers
for that movie
side note 2 you probably also heard jeff
goldblum recently confirmed that he
filmed scenes with robert
downey jr for the avengers what if
series so he will be coming back for new
stuff during marvel phase 4. it's just
on kevin feige
and marvel to find compelling reasons
for him to come back in the live action
movies like young avengers or the future
avengers movies
is a hologram or a special message that
he left behind that they find
just some compelling reason for him to
come back and play the character
aside from him just straight up coming
back alive or an alternate universe
version
the other reason why she says this too
she can't say whether or not he's alive
is because they were playing it like he
might never
come back in the future and even this
version of morgan stark that iron man is
talking to
isn't the actual morgan stark it's just
a piece of her soul that he's connected
to because of the power of the combined
infinity
stones it's kind of complicated what's
happening here the mechanics of it all
but the stones are reaching forward in
time and connecting him to a piece of
her soul
pulling it into the soul world you have
to remember that most of the movie is
about them
traveling back into the past but you can
actually use the infinity gauntlet to
travel to any point in the future that
you want to
they have a nice callback to the i love
you 3000 line from earlier in the movie
and then after this what would have
happened is they had the avengers take a
knee deleted scene where they do a much
bigger longer version of the goodbye
scene with spider-man pepper potts and
roadie
here's a short clip of that iron man 1
was
incredibly special we sort of improv the
whole thing
we laughed we cried we got very very
close on that movie we were the first
marvel movie
as a studio you know there was no real
model for it yet
nobody expected too much of it i think
most of us have been pretty
vocal about what he started and without
him
none of us would be in this position the
scene goes on even longer you can even
see younger gamora from 2014 get all
awkward when they start getting down on
one knee because she never met iron man
she doesn't know tony stark so she's
like peace
i'm out of here that's why peter quill
and thor the guardians of the galaxy are
plotting a course to track her ship down
at the end of the movie in that other
scene
but you watch those iron man scenes and
you probably understand why they chose
to delete them
the iron man soul world scene is cool
but the whole reason why the writers
said that they originally tried to
include it
was to make iron man feel like things
would be okay he made the right call
in the much shorter scene with pepper
potts saying
tony we're going to be okay and
spider-man saying goodbye
right after this moment also does the
exact same thing in half the time so you
would have had two separate scenes doing
the exact same thing
the other big reason why they cut it is
because they showed the scene to test
audiences
and most of the people were confused
about who morgan stark was katherine
langford they didn't make the connection
that she was the older version of this
young little girl
and for the people that did recognize
who she was supposed to be
because you've only spent a couple of
scenes with the young morgan stark
character
most of the people watching didn't
really care that much about her so the
scene didn't wind up carrying the weight
that they wanted it to and for most
casual viewers it just made things more
confusing
the reason why they cut the avengers
take a knee scene is because it was
originally there to just have everyone
pay tribute to iron man sacrifice
and they also do that again right after
this during the funeral scene
so they cut it for pretty much the same
reason why they cut the soul world
scene you're doing just the same scene
over and over again making the film
longer than it needs to be and they
found that they were turning the ending
of the movie into a lord of the rings
return to the kings situation
remember how that movie had several
different endings
like the whole last 15 to 20 minutes of
return of the king was a bunch of
different ending scenes
when really you only want one or two and
then any other tags that you want with
the different characters you handle in
the post-credits scenes because it's a
marvel movie but the issue they said
they had with avengers end game is that
they wanted the movie to feel special
like a real ending for some of these
characters even though they're
definitely coming back in black widow
like black widow died but technically
the black widow movie is set during the
past so it's not quite as perfect a
situation as they would like
but that's the whole reason why they
didn't want a post credit scene like you
would see in a traditional marvel film
and instead did that special montage
post-credit scene with all the titles
and then the iron man audio taken from
the cave scene in the first iron man
movie with him banging the hammer
making that mark one armor but let me
know in the comments do you
think that they were right to cut the
soul world scene in the scene of them
taking a knee after iron man died
there's a ton of other bonus content and
deleted scenes from the avengers
infinity saga box set from all the
different marvel films going back to
phase one
let me know if there are any special
videos that you want me to make because
most of this stuff is obviously for
avengers end game but there's way more
stuff going back to the other films
i'm working on a new video for the
mandalorian about yoda's race
in their history that should post later
tonight but while you wait for
everything click here for that brand new
avengers what if
trailer and click here for all my
avengers endgame deleted scenes videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you